[Musica]
[Applauso]
quanti di noi possiede una bicicletta
come immaginavo tutti ne abbiamo un gran
bello strumento la bicicletta la prendi
si monta in sella la usi per andare a
fare la spesa o per fare sport latakia
ad un palo e la lasci fuori a casa fuori
casa o la conservi come la cosa più
preziosa che esiste al mondo
qualsiasi sia l'uso che ne fai arrivi al
punto di consumarne o rovinarne il
copertone
ed è qui che tutti noi ci troviamo a
cestinare un prodotto molto speciale e
particolare
silvio stato un attimo credo sia
opportuno spiegare prima che siamo la
nostra storia io sì io siamo due
fratelli cresciuto come penso molti di
noi in questa sala non lontano da qui
dove i nostri nonni ci dicevano frasi
del tipo non buttare mai via niente
prima o poi ti serve per qualcosa
possiamo dire di avere avuto un'infanzia
normale mamma casalinga babbo operaio
tutto nella norma una volta finite le
scuole dell'obbligo nei primi anni
duemila
abbiamo salutato i nostri genitori e
siamo partiti per l'estero scegliendo
strade ed esperienze diverse
andando incontro ad un futuro che non ci
saremmo mai aspettati questa scelta ci
ha messo davanti a due universi così
distanti tra loro la nostra cultura
rurale ed il mondo intero con le sue
persone usi e costumi tutti diversi
abbiamo imparato lingue lingue diverse
assaporato cibi conosciuto nuovi amici
ma soprattutto ci siamo trovati a
confrontarci con un mondo del lavoro
molto selettivo e allo stesso tempo
professionale e meritocratico come può
essere gestire un pub a londra o i
clienti di un hotel di lusso a parigi
abbiamo passato in questo modo nove anni
della nostra vita nel 2013
sentivamo però la necessità di
ritrovarci di rincontrarci detto fatto
abbiamo deciso di licenziarsi dal lavoro
salutato gli amici partiti di nuovo una
vacanza
[Applauso]
due fratelli una vacanza a tempo
indeterminato e un biglietto di sola
andata per noi era fondamentale per
incrociare le nostre strade e e
condividere idee e progetti che avevamo
messo da parte negli anni negli anni
passati
immaginate decidiamo di incontrarsi in
un hotel a doha in qatar già detta così
sembra
sono quasi l'inizio di un film doha
grattacieli e deserto caldo torrido
all'esterno e freddo dentro ai locali
umidità folle l'odore di spezie dei
quartieri popolari ci sentivamo in uno
dei grandi crocevia del mondo
il primo oggetto che le ho mostrato
appena ci siamo incontrati è stato per
l'appunto un oggetto che sarebbe stato
fonte di un grande stravolgimento delle
nostre vite nei mesi a seguire
ho iniziato a raccontarvi di quel giorno
a rotterdam
tornando dal lavoro anni prima
ovviamente in bicicletta
ho iniziato a ripensare ad una mia
vecchia cintura comprata negli stati
uniti un viaggio precedente rotta è
ormai in disuso però ricordando le
parole del nonno aveva messo da parte la
fibbia un po perché non si sa mai
quel giorno guardando la strada davanti
a me e seguendo il ritmo dei pedali ho
immaginato il copertoncini non più come
la ruota ma bensì la striscia perfetta
per la fibbia messa da parte
mesi prima eccola qui ecco qua quello
che abbia mostrato quel giorno ma sono
qui a dirvi che l'idea mi aveva proprio
colpito colpito così tanto che per tutto
il resto del viaggio non abbiamo fatto
altro che che pensare ea immaginare
questa cintura fatta con un copertoncini
di bici da corsa
un materiale che al termine del suo
utilizzo viene regalata una nuova vita
una vita molto più lunga
rispetto al motivo per cui era stato
prodotto in fase iniziale
immaginate a un materiale forte dalla
potenza etica di di una produzione senza
scarti fatto a mano totalmente da noi
due
prendendo un prodotto industriale fino a
trasformarlo in un pezzo unico e
artigianale beh giunti a questo punto
non ci restava altro che rifare le
valigie prendere un volo verso casa
nostra l'italia a presenza e iniziare
una nuova avventura insieme un nuovo
sogno diverso da quelli affrontati fino
a quel momento chiamandolo per nome
cycle fin dal primo giorno ci siamo resi
conto che fare impresa è difficile
coniugare la nostra inesperienza con un
mondo difficile quale è quello della
moda così volubile e altalenante
confrontarsi con una burocrazia
incredibilmente complicata ed una
clientela che non avendo mai visto un
prodotto simile un po diffidente
distaccata non sono state cose facili da
superare
la vera sfida è stato sono stati
superare i momenti di difficoltà e
rispetterà e rispettare le nostre alte
aspettative
e sapete come abbiamo fatto credendo
fortemente nel nostro progetto e
perseverando nonostante tutto
ogni piccolo traguardo raggiunto è stato
per noi come benzina sul fuoco della
nostra auto motivazione e col passare
del tempo ci siamo ci stavamo rendendo
conto che stavamo diventando dei veri e
propri imprenditori e la nostra bandiera
l'economia circolare sapete il
significato di economia circolare
secondo me lo conosciamo un po tutti
sotto un altro nome
il riutilizzo e infatti al giorno d'oggi
la valorizzazione degli scarti di
produzione
l'estensione del ciclo di vita dei
prodotti l'app cycling l'uso di energie
da fonti rinnovabili
tutte queste cose comprendono il
significato di economia circolare
e sapete cosa questi valori li abbiamo
scolpiti come principi fondamentali del
messaggio che portiamo avanti ogni
giorno mostrandolo ad ogni evento cui
partecipiamo sia esso grande o piccolo
in italia o all'estero
rendendoci conto che sempre più persone
ed aziende sono sensibili a questo a
questi importanti valori e cercano di
metterlo in atto nella vita di ogni
giorno
a dare manforte si aggiungono le
politiche comunitarie che sono i
pilastri guida dell'unione europea vedi
la recente messa al bando di cannucce
bicchieri e posate di plastica
spostando l'attenzione ad una produzione
e consumo di prodotti che rientrano nell
etica dell'economia circolare e non a
caso pochi mesi fa siamo stati
contattati da un grosso produttore di
pneumatici davvero grosso fidatevi il
quale con nostro sorpresa ed orgoglio ci
ha definito ci ha definiti i quali punti
di riferimento nel riutilizzo del loro
materiale tanto la non vuole essere
autocelebrativo anzi ma siamo qui a
spiegare che non stiamo non stiamo
seguendo
nessun libro nessuna strada già battuta
siamo qui a cercare di far capire che
ognuno di noi non solo a parole ma ma
anche con i fatti e con dei prodotti che
passano di mano in mano possiamo essere
noi tutti quelli che riescono a cambiare
il modo di pensare di vivere e di fare
business
questa è la nostra storia
[Applauso]